is something I really appreciate about
you is that
you have your performing persona
and I've noticed whenever I'd come in
and talked to you and the dressing room
beforehand or afterwards or even when I
talk to you here today at the podcast
you are
a very quiet thoughtful man yeah and I'm
curious
if you encounter
you're so well known out in the world
when you're yourself you're with your
family with the kids
there are there people that want that
other Sebastian do you know what I mean
and you are a very dignified intelligent
quiet guy who is not performing at this
moment yeah people do think that's uh
who I am on an everyday basis you know
kind of not loud but like overexpressive
and whatnot when I get together with you
we're just kind of talking it's normal
and what have you so yeah listen I I'm
not I'm not life at a party by any means
all right and I think that's the
misconception with some comedians where
you think oh invite the comedian's gonna
make the room laugh
you know if you invite me over to your
house and there's other people there
that I don't know I tend to be you know
Allen's call it Shy just and I tend to
it takes me a while yeah to warm up to
the group yeah even when when I do these
things right these podcasts which I
don't when I don't do a lot of them just
because
I mean I don't know I just feel like uh
is is this going to be an environment
where I'm gonna be comfortable to kind
of be myself and like express my
feelings and then obviously with the U6
I fit right in here
we like to think it's a welcoming
environment
no but like sometimes you go in it's
like I don't you know I don't know but
what do we know well also I've noticed
that
um people a lot of people think comedy
is a thing like you hire a plumber they
come over
oh I see what the problem is and they
fix it and I'm always trying to explain
to people they'll say like why don't you
just come over into this situation and
and do that Conan thing and get
everybody laughing and I'll start asking
questions like whoa what's what's what's
the occasion what's the room what's the
and they act like what are you talking
about just come and do the thing yeah
and I'll say it's all comedy is so hard
and it's also so conditional on where
are we
where are we who's there what's the back
story as you know if there's a really
high ceiling that's not good yeah you
want some compression in the room if
people are eating while you're doing
your thing that's not good that's
terrible yeah I've have nightmares still
doing things at the you know
um uh what's what's the really fancy
hotel that goes back way Waldorf Astoria
oh Waldorf Astoria has it yeah the world
of Astoria has this famous Ballroom
where they would do whenever someone was
retiring like Tom Brokaw is retiring
Conan go do you know you're gonna go and
talk about Tom and get big laughs for 15
minutes at the Waldorf Astoria and you
think there's a ballroom there that I
have still have nightmares about because
it's really wide really deep ceilings
are really high and everybody's eating a
Caesar salad
and you just hear you know silverware
and I think again and again and again
it's about
what's the context what's the room
what's the environment yeah and you know
when you're in an environment where you
can really light things on fire and have
fun and you also know when you're in an
environment where
what is this an aquarium like why am I
here yeah these people I don't even
think know that there's going to be
anybody doing anything funny it just
feels it's very off-putting and you need
the conditions to be right yeah I think
uh that's the misconception you could
just put comedy up wherever and it's
just gonna work I remember early on
where people you know you know a little
corporate event you know corporate
events generally speaking are notorious
for this we're like yeah no we're gonna
have a comedian and then you get there
and then it's just a dance floor and
then the people you know it's like you
got to have the people near me you know
you can't be you know 40 feet away right
you're not Mussolini yeah you know you
need you need people yes exactly exactly
so then you would have to do a quick
adjustment and go all right I'm going to
perform now on the Dance Floor now I'm
gonna have to go you know and so you got
to make it right and it works in life
too I think you know sometimes I think
you're in a situation where it's a
social setting and you know maybe the
expectation is you know for uh you to be
funny but you look at the environment
and go this this ain't this ain't the
environment for for me to like Excel
here so then I then I go like I'm like a
shut-in I don't say nothing and then my
wife's like why aren't you talking like
it's just it's just not right you know
like it's it's uh yeah I don't know I
feel uncomfortable sometimes around like
um went to a birthday party yesterday
kids birthday party right
I just uh I don't know I just felt like
I'm just gonna hang out with my kids
here because I just didn't feel like any
like Pockets or any situations where I
could get involved and really kind of
start to get something cooking yeah yes
I know exactly what you're talking about
I was at a Thing Once I was at an event
that I was supposed to that I emceed and
they didn't tell me this but it was all
to raise
it was a really good cause was to raise
money for uh you know wounded uh wounded
uh military vets and so it's a great
cause and I was really glad to do it
it's this big event I'll never forget
I'm backstage and I'm gonna go out and I
know what I'm gonna do and just before I
went out they came out and they played
Taps
you know and they played they played
Taps and the whole room gets really
solemn and then a voice of God just went
ladies and gentlemen Conan O'Brien
he's like
the
it's like a dare you know
how do I get from where we are now which
is very sacred and solemn and
appropriate but why did you why did you
want to communicate
yeah I think we're going to light it up
you know like oh it's very somber now
the comedian's gonna come out and make
everybody laugh but I mean it's
difficult to come out to uh to that
environment I did something similar to
it I was a 911 gig and they show a video
of 9 11 and the people and this and that
and then they're please welcome
Sebastian and I come out and I'm like
okay uh you know let's get into the my
dad my dad
or else so you're doing you're doing
comedy about how you've had a hard day
oh boy the day I've had oh really did
Two Towers collapse
and thousands and thousands of people
hold on hold on I know I know but let me
talk about my day I mean it's just
impossible yeah it's like a Harry
Houdini thing where it's like we're
gonna take Sebastian mascalco and wrap
chains around him and put him in a bank
vault and throw them in the Hudson River
and then let's see if he can get out
yeah
um you know it's funny because you
mentioned something that I like to talk
about occasionally which is
um you talk about
life of the party and this is a common
misconception
but I've often had people over the years
say to me oh you must have been the
class clown and I've mentioned this
before in the podcast and I think oh no
I was not the class clown
I I remember the class clown but and I
but I was not that guy
and most I would say almost
all of the comedians I really like
we're not the class clown and I'm sure
there are so many people that are huge
fans of yours and would think like oh my
God if I could have gone if I could have
been in the eighth grade with Sebastian
he would have just been
hanging from the ceiling and being crazy
and I just knowing you and how smart you
are and talented I'm thinking now I
don't think that was Sebastian yeah uh
no one if you were in eighth grade with
me you would have not known I was in the
class
I actually looked at the class clown as
I was sitting watching him going
sit down
it's not fun
yeah so you know I was I was more of an
observer I I wasn't the uh
I wasn't the center of attention now
when I got up in front of the class to
do a book report or if it was something
that I had to get up and and do then I
was funny but like you know the rest of
the year I was I wasn't saying much so
never the class clown I never thought
the class clown was funny I could tell
who the class clown is if if it's a
comedian that guy was the
I'm not in the class clowns yeah no well
I think they're all they all end up in
prison at least for a while
do routinely go to prison
and then they come out and they're not
class clowns anymore
they have a whole different attitude
about stuff isn't as funny to them
anymore